hier haben wir muttersöhnchen aus
schleswig holstein mit dem wunderbaren
titel essen gehen ich würde mal
behaupten das ist die schrägste nun mal
die ja läuft auf den buvisoco oder wie
seht ihr das das musst du sagen wir
finden ist die beste nummer aber wenn du
sagst ist es die schrägste nehmen wir
das auch hin okay die beste das heißt
ihr wollt gewinnen unbedingt
wir wollen wir wir finden wir sollten
gewinnen aber ich denke nicht dass wir
gewinnen werden also wie wir das auch
schon mal gesagt haben wir wir erwarten
platz eins rechnen aber mit platz 16
oder schlechter aber wir sollten uns
natürlich gewinnen
ich habe noch nicht so ganz raus wie ich
euch wenn ich in einer eher wie schon
gesagt als journalist beim will ja immer
die leute in der schublade einsortieren
seit er in irgendeiner oder liege ich da
komplett daneben mit dieser vermutung
also ich denke wir suchen die schublade
noch aber wir haben schon ein begriff
für unsere musik den haben wir auch
selber kreiert hybrid elektro nennen wir
das also wenn du dafür ist gerne eine
schublade neu beschriften willst mach es
gern hybrid elektro das ist in der nähe
von
elektronischer musik kraftwerk
nicht aber wenn ich dann wenn ich deine
mailbox mehr anhören die ansage das hört
sich verdammt nach kraftwerken weil sie
diese vocoder sei ja bestimmt aber dass
der hybrid elektro heißt dass deswegen
weil wir im normalen musikerleben keine
elektronik künstler sind sondern wir
präsentieren uns jetzt hier beim
bundesvision song contest so war das
einfach dieser fernseher rahmen ist aber
wenn du ein live-konzert von
muttersoehnchen besuchs wird dort live
musik gemacht also ich bin eigentlich
von hause aus schlagzeuger und er ist
keyboarder und
wir machen hybrid elektro deswegen weil
wir elektronische musik machen die aber
durchsetzt ist und kreiert wird durch
organische instrumente also wir sind
kein elektro act in dem sinne aber
kraftwerk ist auf jeden fall eine band
von der ich mich niemals distanzieren
würde zumal das ist einfach der eine der
wichtigsten bands emma ist da muss man
jetzt den leuten sagen die jetzt sie auf
youtube dieses video gucken die kennen
das wahrscheinlich nicht mehr kraftwerk
war eine der großen elektronischen bands
der 70er und 80er jahre ja ich würde
sagen kraftwerk ist ist ohne kraftwerk
apps alles das wozu die kids heute
abfeuern selbst nicht also direkt die
waren ihrer zeit dermaßen voraus sowohl
technologisch als auch kompositorisch
als auch grad sozusagen
einfach eine bahnbrechende band ohne die
ist würde ich sagen nichts gibt was
irgendwie nichts gäbe was ansatzweise
mit computer musik und im
computergenerierter technologischer
musik zu tun hat die haben die ersten
computer quasi schon für musik
eingesetzt die es damals gab
ganz bestimmte stt kreierten waren
einfach hammer kraftwerk vorher war aber
jetzt heißt muttersöhnchen forever
stefan raab hat es ja auch schon
formuliert er sieht euch ihr seht euch
ganz weit vorne er ist meint es ist
schon gewöhnungsbedürftig warum
sollten weit vorne sein wir sehen uns
aber ganz hinten und das nur um das
klarzustellen
wirklich ganz hinten weil weil jetzt mal
ganz realistisch also uns kennt keiner
wir sind aus dem nichts aufgetaucht und
ich denke das ist hier so eine mediale
macht das ganze da kann man nicht
gewinnen aber die sind auch nicht
wirklich hier um zu gewinnen nur wir
wollen jetzt nicht falsch verstanden
werden und glauben wir würden das
gewinnen wir sollten das gewinnen aber
wir werden es sich gewinnen also auch
egal euer motto ist dabei ist alles er
weiß alles so riesig
spaß haben und dabei ist alles so
irgendwie gut aber ich glaube ihr habt
eine chance weil ihr werdet supported
und zwar von eurem youtube partner und
es ist niemand geringeres als ali was
gedacht man von einer echten ferrari von
bloody und bald ist es wieder soweit
bundesvision songcontest 2011 auf
prosieben mich als schleswig holsteiner
und viele denken ich wohne in hamburg wo
ja quasi direkt neben hamburg noch in
schleswig-holstein möchte dafür die band
die mutter sind jan unterstützen nicht
über eventim ziemlich einen namen hat
wenn es auch an sich ziemlich geil und
verdient es für schleswig holstein zu
gewinnen wenn ihr die band unterstützen
wollt dann gebt dem video ihren daumen
hoch und sobald dann auf prosieben die
action abgeht anrufe nicht vergessen auf
jeden fall viel glück an die
muttersöhnchen und toi toi toi vielen
dank juli für den gallen support
muttersöhnchen für schleswig holstein
wir rocken was wir können und ihr
wolltet was ihr könnt und danke für den
support und wählen wählen wählen weil
wir einfach nummer die geilsten sind die
so unbedingt